[Music]
on this saturday night
copen 19 records in canada new
brunswick's bubble
about to burst it makes me really sad to
think
we could lose our gains at the very last
minute
ontario sets a new daily high what we
need are federal rules
as canadians feel the burden of new
restrictions and lockdowns
post brexit and canada it's a win-win
for two
close allies and friends why ottawa was
in a rush to get a trade agreement with
britain
and will the new american president help
free the two canadian men
in china
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with the spike in
kova 19 cases in just about every part
of the country
alberta shattered its daily record with
more than 1300 cases
saskatchewan reported a record high of
439 new cases
ontario also broke a new daily record of
nearly
1600 cases so did new brunswick
23 new cases in that province another
sign the atlantic bubble
may be bursting this is indeed a reality
check
everything we're hearing worldwide
everything we're hearing nationally
from other provinces is real we've said
here time and time again
that the potential is that it will come
to new brunswick
we're seeing it david aiken now on a
nation bracing for more dark days
ahead so here we are it's november
november 21st 2020
we have come a long way since the
beginning of this pandemic
that's new brunswick inside the atlantic
bubble the part of the country
that has been best beating back covet 19
and yet even there the number of new
daily cases hit
a new record on saturday and so new
brunswick like
many other parts of the country now
telling its citizens
it's time to step up we have to do this
again
records are being set in regions across
the country
saskatchewan hit a one-day record with
439 cases and
ontario hit a high with 1588
new infections ontario premier doug ford
had already moved to put the millions
who live
and work in toronto and a nearby peel
region
into lockdown starting monday that
prompted panic buying saturday across
the greater toronto area
premiers the prime minister and public
health officials everywhere
are sounding the alarm that all
canadians must do more
now to stop the spread well here within
nunavut we don't recommend any
unnecessary travel right now at all so
i don't know if it's solution but our it
is uh
it is one of the tools we have here to
keep the
cove from going to other communities
we're asking
business owners we're asking patrons
to follow the rules but the rules are
different
all over the country and that to some
experts is a problem
what we need are federal rules on mass
use on closures of high-risk
businesses on keeping gatherings
small on closing off
the hot spots of the country drawing a
circle around them and not letting
people in or out
except for urgent needs just like the
maritimes have done
so far though ottawa's answer it's up to
the provinces
and the premiers to make those decisions
david aiken global news ottawa
it has been exactly 10 months since the
first novel coronavirus case was
confirmed in the u.s
as of today there have been more than 12
million infections in the world's worst
affected country
new covenant case numbers are breaking
records day after day
hospitalizations are rising so rapidly
that military medical professionals are
being called in to help with staff
shortages
and still tens of millions of americans
are expected to travel for thanksgiving
over the next week despite warnings to
stay put
jennifer johnson reports from washington
the u.s department of health reports
over one thousand hospitals spanning all
50 states
are critically short on staff as the
kova 19 pandemic infects
record numbers of americans day after
day i have
never seen so much death
and so much sickness in the past two
weeks
than i have in my entire 10 years in
health care
in north dakota which has one of the
highest death tolls per capita
air force nurses are being called in to
alleviate staff shortages
in oregon new cases hospitalizations and
deaths
are setting daily records other states
are seeing dramatic spikes and
positivity rates too
it's rather shocking but about one in
every 49 coloradans are contagious with
this
dodger stadium in los angeles is one of
hundreds of sites across the country
flooded with people lining up to be
tested right now we have a pandemic that
is completely out of control
and the reason it's out of control is we
still don't have the public health
infrastructure to test trace and isolate
and without that people can't know their
status they go about their lives and
they infect other people
the u.s centers for disease control and
prevention is recommending people not
travel this thanksgiving holiday but the
american automobile association predicts
close to 50 million americans
will go out of town to celebrate with
loved ones we felt like we're being safe
and
he's going to get tested before he sees
his grandma many college students feel
they had no choice but to come home
campus actually is closing their like
dorm like living in actual dorm
more shutdowns have been ordered no more
indoor dining at restaurants in several
u.s cities
including philadelphia business is so
bad at the moment that
we're not making rent a new study by the
cdc has found government mandates that
require masks
dramatically slow the spread of covet 19
yet some states are making mass
mandatory
while others still are not that
state-by-state approach to fighting the
pandemic is something president-elect
joe biden plans to change
when he takes office january 20th
jennifer johnson
global news washington under a new
american administration
canada has an opportunity to fix the
fractures in our relationship with the
u.s
especially when it comes to the china
file ottawa has been caught in the
middle of a war between beijing and d.c
on the west block this week mercedes
stephenson spoke with joe biden
insider and delaware senator chris coons
about shifts
in foreign policy mercedes robin the
rumors circulating in washington
suggests that a top pick to be
president-elect biden's secretary of
state
is senator chris coons senator coons
gave us some insights into what
canada can expect in terms of relations
with the biden administration
and he says that key republicans who are
backing president trump
might be changing their tune in the next
week as more states certify
the outcome of their elections that
means there is no
further uh review or recount
possible once they certify their
elections the last
conceivable date would be december 14th
when our
college of electors meet um but you know
frankly
every day that we are delaying is a day
that puts at greater risk our public
health and our national security
there's a lot to watch out for come
inauguration day and canadians will
certainly be watching closely too
as policy shifts under the new
administration will have consequences
for canada
top of mind for canadians biden's policy
on china
it's been almost two years since
canadians michael spavor and michael
coverig were arbitrarily detained in
china
following the arrest of huawei cfo mong
wang zhou in canada
on a u.s extradition warrant if it were
up to me
i would be pressing harder on the
chinese to release
these two canadians who are held without
cause and frankly to
consult closely with prime minister
trudeau
someone who i view as a close and
trusted ally uh and who i believe
will enjoy a very good relationship with
president-elect biden
um but you know frankly in consultation
with a partner and ally
uh we'd be asking the president-elect
would be asking exactly what is in
canada's best interest
as well as what's in the united states
best interest senator coons says china
has become
more aggressive globally he predicts
that president-elect biden will
pull international partners like canada
together to come up with a coordinated
strategy on china
questions remain on the future of
canada's trading relationship with our
southern neighbors though
under a biden administration our long
and close partnership has at times
had some strains due to trait whether
it's softwood lumber or dairy or even
lobsters
we at times have had some disagreements
but we should resolve them
the way close and trusted friends do we
will all certainly be watching those
discussions closely over here in canada
robin mercedes-stevenson in ottawa and
you can watch the full interview with
senator chris coons on the west block
tomorrow
right here on global canada has an
important relationship with the uk too
it's one of our largest trading partners
and tonight canada has a deal with the
united kingdom
done in the nick of time here's our
europe bureau chief
crystal gamansing the uk is our fifth
largest uh trading partner in the world
uh so making sure that we continue to do
even with the poor audio in the video
chat there's no missing the message
these four are celebrating the new
canada united kingdom
trade continuity agreement it maintains
access to 20 billion pounds
worth of trade trade that because of
brexit could have been more
costly and cumbersome in 2021
when european union trade rules no
longer apply to britain
or its partners the new agreement
replicates sections of the comprehensive
economic and trade agreement
also known as ceta while the full text
has not been made public
it appears canadian businesses didn't
gain anything
but nothing was lost either it also
protects canada supplied managed
products so i want to be very clear that
there is no
new market access for cheese here in
this transition
agreement well this transitional trade
agreement is being
hailed as a success by government
officials in ottawa
and here in the uk trade organizations
are a little more hesitant
for example the canadian agri-food trade
alliance says that this is a
welcomed stop gap but governments need
to do
more to help businesses that point was
reiterated by tracy gray the
conservative shadow minister in a
statement
saying we've heard from many industries
who would like to see
amendments and it sounds like three
years of negotiations
haven't led to this materializing when
brexit talks first started in 2017
canada and the uk committed to keeping
its trading relationship
intact now the pressure is on canadian
politicians to determine
if the agreement should be passed we
don't have the text of the treaty
we don't have the text of the enabling
legislation daniel blakey doubts there's
enough time for
anyone to truly scrutinize the deal if
both governments approve it leaders say
it will stand for at least a year
and they've committed to creating a new
ambitious
and permanent trade deal crystal
commencing global news
london a mostly virtual g20 summit is
underway in saudi arabia with the
spotlight on a unified effort to control
the kova 19 pandemic
the annual gathering of leaders from the
world's 20 biggest economies kicked off
with a discussion on managing the
financial recovery
once the pandemic is under control and
in his opening remarks
saudi arabia's king called for
cooperation to ensure equal and
affordable access to vaccines and drugs
to battle coven 19.
coming up a former prime minister's
perspective on the vaccine his father
had to make a health decision for canada
our hopes are pinned on the new vaccines
promising to change the course of this
pandemic but there are reasons to be
cautious
in the 1950s an american company
produced and distributed
a polio vaccine that made children sick
at the time
canada's health minister was paul martin
senior
his son the former prime minister is
sharing that story tonight and as mike
armstrong explains
it may be a reason to have confidence in
covind 19 vaccines
he was in a foul home there is a day
paul martin has never forgotten the
former prime minister was 16 years old
and found his father
at home upset and i'd never seen him
like that paul martin senior was the
federal health minister at the time
the polio vaccine was just being rolled
out and
vaccinated kids in the southern u.s were
turning up
sick nobody knew if it was a bad batch
or if in fact there was a problem
with the vaccine the americans stepped
in
and stopped the vaccine right across the
country right across the country
it would become known as the cutter
incident a company in california
cutter laboratories had in fact produced
a bad batch of the new polio vaccine
instead of immunizing children with an
inactivated or
killed strain of the virus healthy kids
were being injected
with live poliovirus forty thousand
developed a mild form of the infection
more than 150 were paralyzed permanently
and ten died but paul martin senior
confident in canada's supply
never buckled to the pressure to stop
the program
if he had stopped in canada
that would have stopped the vaccine in
north america that would that would have
that would have kept the balance instead
the u.s investigated
figured out what had happened and looked
north
canada had continued vaccinating kids
and everything was going fine
the americans restarted their program
now martin says
one factor in his father's decision was
their family's
history both he and his father had
suffered from polio
he didn't want another child to miss
getting the vaccine
he knew what it meant to have holy now
with the world again looking for a
vaccine to solve a problem
martin says he's been thinking about the
cutter incident he says the industry
learned from what went wrong is there
the potential
that we would cut corners or rush a
vaccine out
certainly from what i have seen no but
your point is
is well taken i think they're going
through all of the testing they're
taking their time they're doing it right
it was dr jonas salk out of pittsburgh
who developed the polio vaccine
but canada was deeply involved toronto's
cannot labs
shipped thousands of liters of
poliovirus to salk for his work
martin says he's confident in a covid19
vaccine
because he's seen what science can
achieve
mike armstrong global news montreal
and you can see more of that story
tonight on the new reality with donna
friesen
starting at 7 p.m still ahead a
staggering humanitarian crisis
unfolding in ethiopia's deadly conflict
[Music]
and liftoff of sentinel 6 michael
freilich
nasa launched a new satellite into
earth's orbit to analyze the planet's
rising sea levels the sentinel 6 was
developed with the european space agency
it will send signals to the ocean's
surface tracking elevation based on
how long they take to return the data
will help climate change research
and improve weather forecasts
ethiopian forces are pushing further
into tigray where a deadly conflict is
forcing
thousands of people to flee to
neighboring sudan according to the
united nations at least 32
000 civilians have left tigre so far and
children under the age of 18 account for
45 of the refugees arriving in sudan
the ethiopian government says it has
seized the second biggest city in tigre
as troops advanced towards its capital
ethiopia's prime minister
a nobel peace prize winner is under
pressure to enter talks with the leaders
of the rebellious region
but as redmond shannon reports both
sides are accused of stoking the
tensions
that are leading to a humanitarian
crisis
ethiopian prime minister abi ahmed
received the nobel peace prize
less than a year ago there are
those who have never seen war but
glorify
and romanticize it they have not seen
the fear abby was given the award for
his work in ending a
two-decade conflict with eritrea that
killed
tens of thousands of people these are
ethiopians today
running from a conflict between abi's
troops and the northern tigray region
people haven't eaten for three or four
days i don't know where my kids are
says this man who has fled to sudan
tensions rose in september when tigre
held regional elections
defying a national ban on polls imposed
because of coed 19.
then earlier this month abby accused the
ruling tplf in tigre
of attacking a federal military base he
sent in troops and the effects are now
being felt
across eastern africa the un says tens
of thousands of people have left
tigre for sudan ethiopia has reportedly
moved
three thousand of its peacekeeping
forces from unstable somalia
into tigre and the tplf has fired
rockets into eritrea
accusing it of supporting ethiopia's
offensive
for 27 years until 2018 the tigray
minority led
ethiopia's government during which time
it fought a war against the breakaway
nation of eritrea
that was until abby took power two years
ago
freezing out the tplf and striking a
peace deal with eritrea as president
they didn't really take lightly the idea
of marginalization
in ethiopia after being dominant for so
long
the tigran's election defiance this year
was part of a push for autonomy
that they see abby attempting to strip
away
many people simply now suspect that he
is building
a typical african political system
called personal rule
even there is if there is election i
think many people simply believe that he
may not be
allowing free and fair elections
it's believed hundreds have died in the
tigray conflict it includes allegations
the tplf were behind
a mass killing something they deny but
with a total communication blackout in
tigre
little is known for sure redmond shannon
global news
london up next the humboldt broncos
survivor and his message about managing
mental health
tyler smith has been through more than
most people could imagine
in 2018 he survived the tragic humboldt
broncos bus
crash that killed so many of his friends
smith still grapples with the trauma
but he's working to move forward as
sulingo reports he's now helping other
people his age
deal with mental health we came to the
rink
every day and we knew that it was truly
a great day to be a bronco no matter
what
as one of the 13 survivors of the bus
crash that killed
16 people former humboldt bronco
tyler smith knows he may never fully
heal
i'm still trying to figure out what
truly truly works for me because i mean
i'm still
i mean still it feels like the accident
was yesterday tyler was
seriously injured in the 2018 collision
he still has nerve damage to his left
hand
but the emotional trauma affects him the
most
a few months after the crash depression
sunk
in that numbness kind of triggers into a
spiral down effect um it did for me at
least where
where you just bottle up all these
emotions and you just put them on the
back burner and then
obviously there's going to be a time
when it comes out
he managed to return to the broncos to
play 10 games
that's when he realized he needed to go
home to le duke
to focus on his mental health and
actually start to
to figure out ways to recover and figure
out ways that
work best for me to heal and and realize
that it's not just a one day thing that
this is
this is going to be a lifetime thing
exercise
counseling and writing in his journal
have helped but the pandemic has changed
life for him
and all his friends tyler says people in
their 20s tend to focus on what's next
in school in their careers and their
relationships
that's why isolating can be tough his
advice
try to be grateful for what you have
right now
whether it be a good or a bad day you
just have to embrace that day and
and try to live in the present and and
try to figure out what's going to work
for you that day
sulingo global news and that is global
national for this saturday
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
this snowy night view of kamloops bc
we'd love to see your part of the
country so email your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you